when i wanted to start my own company it
was difficult at the time to do it so i
said i'll start with a vc as well with
venture capital get exposed to it and
then once i'm done learning about it i'm
going to start my own company
22 years later i'm still doing venture
capitals welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello hello and welcome to another
episode of 20 minute leaders today i
have the honor of speaking with ayal
neve managing partner at pitango first
prior to joining bitango ayal was
managing partner at giza vc where he led
the fund operations and focused mainly
on it infrastructure semiconductors and
internet ael serves on the board of
directors of graphcore aa21 lumigo
optibus and others ale's investments
have a primary focus on artificial
intelligence and he's also the
co-founder of the public knowledge
workshop a leading non-profit
organization for freedom of information
as well as take an innovative
impact-driven delivery service which
helps the needy by providing them with
food and delivery service on top of an
on-demand delivery service
beyond your personal
journey and career and the fact that the
way that you're integrating
investments with working with founders
and deep technology
you're part of a family that is really a
cornerstone of israeli tech and and the
story of the startup nation pitango and
specifically your group pitango first
working with with founders and and
looking at companies that really are
changing the paradigm of technology and
the way that that other companies then
leverage technology to
you know to to create products for
people whether it's with graphcore or
optibus or ai-21 it's really phenomenal
and and i'm really excited to unfold a
little bit about your journey and
pitango first and understand this you
know this monster a little bit better so
thank you very much for joining me today
it's a pleasure it's really a pleasure
and then
glad to share that with you
take me back you know a little bit about
south africa a little bit about your own
upbringing which leads you to the
intersection of deep tech and investing
so born and born in israel i moved to
south africa when i was 12 years old um
really loved technology uh from i was
programming from the age of nine years
old
uh and when i moved to uh uh yeah my
father was actually quite advanced at
the time sent me over and said you gotta
learn how to program that's that's a
long time ago that's almost 40 years ago
was he an engineer himself did he
understand
he was an entrepreneur and somebody that
was always uh forward-looking
and thought it made uh a lot of sense
you know i was always good with maths
and uh
she gotta you gotta go and start
programming and i thought you know
what the hell i'm going to start playing
with a computer at the time it was
obviously commodore
64 and things like that spectrum i go to
all that
and he bought the first pc he got from
me i remember i used to go back and
forth to tel aviv to see if it arrived
every time i came to the shop it wasn't
you know it was sort of a shop they told
me no it hasn't arrived yet it took like
a few months until it came through and i
remember i was so happy
um at the time i had a friend xiaomi and
the professor yelamir who actually i
think you interview them
and i used to go every day to their
um apartment in holland and we used to
learn how to program and do all sorts of
things so that was my first
interaction with uh
with computers and with technology and i
was i was fascinated really it was
amazing i then moved to south africa
after spending some time with shai and
the l and learning how to do these
things
and over there it was more about
mathematics and at the age of 16
i started a small company called
super computers
in which we did enterprise application
integration we tried to help research
centers and and hospitals and medical
centers to actually do research and use
pcs while they're using their old uh the
old systems
and at what age was this that was at the
age of 16 and when i was in south africa
uh and then afterwards you know i did
everything
um
in reverse think about it so i started
with a company at the age of 16. i then
went to study actuarial science which is
uh you know statistics and actuaries uh
and i studied actual science and finance
uh in south africa
and then after i finished that i came
back to israel and i went to the israeli
idf to the israeli army and i spent some
uh time with uh unit 217 you probably
know this dude the van
uh where i had a very meaningful time so
that was
you know and also there i had a lot of
interaction with technologies in order
to do our job properly and some some of
your listeners would probably know
uh our uh missions from the uh from the
netflix uh series founder
some of the
some of the actors actually were with me
in the army at the time and it was
pretty pretty intense
and um so that's you know i continued
the reverse method so i started with the
company went to university went to the
army and then i came out of the army i
was here in israel
and exposed to all this good
technologies that are being developed i
said i'm gonna go and start my own
company and when i wanted to start my
own company it was difficult at the time
to do it so i said i'll start with a vc
as well with venture capital get exposed
to it and then once i'm done learning
about it i'm going to start my own
company
22 years later i'm still doing venture
capital so
with a few organizations that are making
extremely high impact on the world um as
well as an entrepreneur so not
necessarily tech businesses but but
still very high impact organizations and
take me back for a second to 16. you're
mentioning you're working
a company called supercomputers and
you're understanding
that technology has the ability to
become a catalyst for research centers
for hospitals for enterprises and the
current tools that we have that the you
know ordinary pc users use they're
they're not sufficient to leverage what
we what what they're capable of what
where was this understanding from what
did this represent this this technology
is a catalyst for you
so basically that time it was you know
more about the necessity of just setting
up the pc
system and and interacting with uh with
old you know as400 and mainframes and
putting the whole thing together at the
time it was so naive that even the
network was was not very prevalent so we
needed to build a network and allow
computers to speak to each other
uh and build the databases
and all of that but we realize that if
you don't centralize everything and you
don't interconnect between uh systems
uh then it it will never work and and it
was so difficult because people had to
enter information as you enter a
hospital into one system and then go and
enter it into another system
and it didn't it didn't uh talk to each
other so you couldn't really research
anything because it was all so
proliferated uh but at the time it was
more about you know uh you know just
putting up a company together with a
friend of mine and trying to make uh
some money and feeling uh
all independent so
that that was just my first exposure
fantastic okay tell me a little bit
about pitango first you have a few
different
you know runs through the vc world you
are you know
embodying you know deep technology
throughout your throughout your journey
and a few years ago you joined bitango
first i believe in 2015. tell me a
little bit about pitango and then your
particular entrance okay
so
uh just just by uh just making sure we
we complete that so before pitango i was
uh with giza venture capital i was
heading there a lot uh
latest fan and then i we we split out
and uh
i um i was uh um
thinking you know where can i uh form a
a fund which will invest in
infrastructure and early stage
and uh i was approached by um
kamikalis and femi and he said you know
why don't you come join us and form a
new focused uh
fund which will only do seeds
investments and i thought what a great
opportunity because it gives uh it gave
me the opportunity to invest in some
deep tech
and have the capability of making early
stage investments with the ability to do
follow-on investments so i think what's
what's unique about tango is that we
have a full stack fund uh we can enter
uh a new investment very early on um and
continue to invest in follow-on
investments all the way up to growth so
we do have a specific uh
seed fund which is pitango first and we
have a growth fund uh
as well as a health tech fund
um and the way we've built it
is actually
quite unique because a lot of people
talk about uh deep tech not many people
do it that's on the one hand so we are
very keen to go into you know ai ai
processors
uh ai is a you know as a deep technology
there are many facets to it
uh we also do quantum computing uh and
and so we are very
oriented towards uh deep tech and on the
other hand we also have an operational
platform uh which we can talk about that
but we have uh you know six six
full-time people just doing uh
operational work for our startups which
gives us quite a bit of uh a unique
proposition and uh and that's just great
and so if we're looking at the
operational side of you know post
investment of seed stage company
infrastructure deep tech in our
ecosystem
what is sort of the relationship with
between pitango first and and a company
you know that because you really do
understand this field and it's beyond
just helping the founder you know with
hiring and with understanding how to
build a company you also understand what
the world needs and you've experienced
this yourself what does this process
look like so first and foremost we try
and do quite a bit of research uh before
every investment we make
and we divide the different sectors
among the partners that are doing early
stage investments in pitango first
uh so that's on the selection side and
then post investment and that partner
would try and support the founders inc
in in finding the right product market
fit which i think is the most important
thing for any uh founding team uh some
of them are you know more advanced and
the more
um um
let's say experienced at doing that so
not every uh founding team needs the
same level of support
so uh and then post investment i would
say
there's a lot of acceleration that needs
to happen and that acceleration is in
the form of hiring uh
so we have a specific hiring person
uh
uh that is totally focused on helping
our portfolio companies uh marketing uh
business development we actually have
you know a a team that is working uh um
around the business development so
there's a there's a whole support team
that that actually on boards a new
company and helps them uh in in
accelerating some of these uh uh
functions
uh and obviously the the i think the the
most important thing is to
help these companies create their own uh
muscle uh whether it's you know uh
marketing
hiring uh or business development the
the idea is not to support them for a
very long time but rather help them to
create that muscle internally
fantastic and if we're looking a little
bit about the types of companies that
that you're really excited about and
already in pitango first you've backed
some
some of the companies were proudest of
you know in our tech because they're not
only amazing companies but but like we
starting from the initial you know few
sentences they're catalysts for change
they're they really are the tectonic
shifts of tech and coming out of israel
so share with me a few of those
companies and a little bit about their
stories so we really try and focus on um
inflective
uh ideas so things that would really
change the world uh some people call
them disruptive technologies but i i
think that there are enablers more than
uh disruptive
uh so to give you an idea for example we
we see that the company called ai21 uh
some of you
some some of the listeners would know i
think you would know it because you're
pretty deep into the ai world
and the idea this is you know i think
it's the it's the ultimate uh it's the
ultimate company um
and the idea behind ai 21 is creating
an ai model that is scalable and much
more efficient than any ai model around
the world
the equivalent would be gpt-3 and that
is doing some great great work
but ai 21 is is creating something
that's much more scalable and much more
efficient
the
um
the marriage between ai and knowledge
representation is creating a much more
effective uh framework
and as a as
as an example they developed their own
uh
personal
writing assistant um
so uh uh professor you of charm and uh
professor amnes
together with origami
whether you know it's a dream team uh
that
we we that we backed uh they've they've
they've been able to uh produce a new
model which they call the jurassic
uh as well as uh prove that their uh
their technology the the technology
behind ai 21 is is providing a better uh
better results so their first
uh product as i said is an is a new my
personal assistant which helps people
with their writing
so
you know it's called virtue so the name
of the of the product is word tune and
uh it's quite amazing at how it works
it's
i i like to call it uh grammarly on
steroids um
it really takes whatever you write
and in you know in real time it
rephrases it uh to to uh uh to the
extent that it it feels really
human-like
uh and it upgrades it whether you want
it to be longer shorter sportier more
polite whatever you want it to be
that technology can unders it actually
understands the context of the sentence
or the paragraph for that matter
and it actually proves that they're
they're making machines understand long
text
uh so that's one product they also have
a read which is amazing
uh they've proved
their technology to be superior to
anything that's available out there and
that's out of vision
tell me a little bit you know you're
you're also you know aa21 is is
incredible you're also involved with
with graphcore optibus
commodore lumigo stream elements
incredible companies there are also more
that i didn't mention
what really you know unifies them is
this enablement and i really want to
understand from you ayal you know where
you know
from the investors perspective your hat
because you're for a second i thought
you were a part of the co-founding team
of a21 the way that you're talking about
the product your passion your
understanding about the impact and and
the details of what's happening there
how do you see yourself as a part of
these journeys what is sort of your role
as you're working with these remarkable
people that are building that's a good
that's a good question um
first and foremost i think it is a
support rule um you know i never try to
uh
to think of myself as
as good as the founders i think the
founders are
uh
the you know they're the pilots they're
the warriors they're the ones that we
need to support we are just a support
system
uh i try and educate myself as much as
possible about their ecosystem about
their technology
and make sure that whatever i say on the
board will not interrupt them but will
only add value
uh at the end of the day you know i see
a lot of companies and many of times
the ability my ability to give them good
advice is just from the fact that i've
i've seen more companies rather than
uh
ever thinking of myself as having more
capabilities
so i try and stay modest and understand
that they are the ones driving
uh they have their hands on the wheel
and i can only make a suggestion
um i think that the most important thing
for as as a board member is stay
educated about what the company's doing
feel the uh have the passion for the
product
you know i expect that from my founders
i love founders who are very passionate
about the product about what they do and
passion is a big thing
and and help them to form the best teams
so
once they have a great team put together
and it's complementary and it's amazing
you know a lot of people can make
mistakes building these teams but if
it's one thing that i like to help them
do is build you know uh a top-notch team
almost like in the basketball team you
know you need to put them together
and win help them to actually hire the
best people
and from there on it's a much smoother
ride much smoother right
now on the on the
perspective of understanding you know
this changing world because you're
looking at companies that if they
succeed they are changing how we are
either developing a technology or
consuming content or
or you know interacting with public
transportation these are big questions
that at the end make a big impact on
people's lives and you have also
responsibility to know whether you're
backing a solution that is going to make
a positive impact or potentially
dangerously a negative one and we've
seen examples throughout history
obviously of tech companies that that
don't do things as as as right as we
would like them to how do you
know how do you think through sort of
that responsibility and that question as
you're making these investments
and you've mentioned a few companies
that i think are
um
are doing some very impactful things i
mean aa21 and optibus
uh stream elements by the way is
creating an amazing platform that
enables a lot of people
um
next site is changing how we interact
with with objects uh we have some really
great companies that i think are really
impacting uh how people are living their
lives
so the one thing we always try and do
and esg is a big part of what we do and
positive impact is a big part of how we
do things both in terms of the products
that we build as well as the internals
of of our portfolio companies so that's
something we've put a lot of effort uh
in in doing an esg we have a full-time
person just for esg internally for
ourselves
and for our foot for the company so
that's very important i think he also
interviewed her cecil so it's it's
really
it's we're really proud of the amazing
plan here in that space so the way we
think about it is you know everything
has to be positive and enabling rather
than you know replacing people enabling
people so for example if i you know if
you look at the ai 21
uh solution it's enabling people that do
not have the riding writing skills
around the world to to work for these
big conglomerates wherever they are so
suddenly they can earn you know they can
they can make a living as if they were
you know top-notch oxford students uh if
you look at uh if you look at optibus
helping people to get better mass
transportation getting to work and from
work in the best possible way uh via via
via transportation another great
breakthrough that is impacting in a very
positive way stream elements are
mentioned helping people make money from
homes i mean this could have been
streamed i'm happy it isn't it isn't a
live live streamed at the moment
uh but it is helping people to earn
money while they're at home so we are
looking at things in a very uh
broad way and how do we enable people
to live a better life and to you know
earn uh earn a living
and uh just making the world a better
place
amazing time that i had here um
fascinating you know we're living in a
super evolution and the companies that
we're talking about here
um they really are changing how we are
building things and and i'm looking back
to
you know learning how to code in nine
and sit in that 16 creating a company
and going to the non-traditional route
of devan
and and experiencing that when you know
that really you know the your role sort
of in your life now is is working with
deep tech and engineering and
understanding you know that you that
through venture capital you can make a
lot of impact and you can and it and it
sounds to me
that your passion is so unique for all
these different companies it's as if
you're working independently with all
these companies and and i almost don't
feel like i'm talking to a venture
capital investor i feel like i'm talking
to an entrepreneur who gets excited
about all these different solutions
which which excites me as a young
entrepreneur and so thank you very very
much for the inspiration and stay safe
and stay healthy and best of luck with
fantastic michael i appreciate it it was
great being here
[Music]